we spoke to parents here from across the
globe all attending this weekend's
mayor's cup Las Vegas mayor's cup all
agreeing that the cost of living
nowadays seems like a never-ending
battle
it's really expensive we spend like a
thousand dollars a week at Costco
Christina Chavez Johnson attending her
children's soccer match at the Las Vegas
mayor's cup Saturday she likes so many
parents visiting for the tournament
sharing their struggles with the rise of
inflation being able to do all the
things definitely is not possible
anymore so we have to kind of pick and
choose and not do them all at once many
parents stating that it was even a
struggle getting to the tournament as
many fellow teammates had to drop out
because of the increase in travel costs
we're really surprised at how expensive
it was to get here we contemplated
driving
the nine ten hours because the flights
the flights weren't so expensive family
of four it we expected it to cost us
uh you know a few hundred bucks uh round
trip and it ended up costing us about
1300 1400 bucks for uh for a round trip
flight from San Francisco to Las Vegas
and parents who flew in internationally
stating the same thing sharing with
eight news now what they've seen in
their own countries well gas prices are
certainly high in Europe anyway
um in the UK it's uh much higher than
the United States at the best of times
so
um the impact on oil in the UK is
certainly been felt very heavily
um and uh so that would be it and then
of course heating prices as well soccer
coach Juan Arroyo who lives in small
Border Town in Mexico says filling up
his tank just isn't what it used to be
as the quality of gas in Mexico has gone
down in his opinion guys in quarters is
like I said it keeps steady but like the
quality of the gas is not the same so
you could put fifty dollars here and
it'll last you but if you put 50 in
Juanes you'll probably get the same
amount but the gas will last you or
maybe two-thirds or whatever the regular
with inflation being high Across the
Nation it's important to note that every
country's economy looks different so for
here Us in the states we're both driven
and Supply related reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now